,
SERIOUS, AND PROBING.
AND THAT IS "THE ANGLE."
ALL RIGHT, JOINING US NOW IS ONE
OF THE FEW WHO QUESTIONS
DR. FAUCI'S EXPERTISE,
SENATOR RAND PAUL.
YOU ARE NOW CALLING FOR THE
FIRING OF ANTHONY FAUCI.
WHAT CAN YOU DO IN THE SENATE TO
GET MORE ANSWERS THAN THE ONES
THAT WE HAVE FROM THE EMAILS
WHICH ARE STILL REDACTED?
>> I THINK WE'VE HAD A SEED
CHANGE OF OPINION.
EVERYBODY LEFT OF CENTER WAS
SAYING THAT THIS WAS A
CONSPIRACY.
NO WAY COULD IT HAVE HAPPENED IN
THE WUHAN LAB.
NOW EVEN DR. FAUCI IS SAYING WE
SHOULD INVESTIGATE IT.
BUT THE EMAILS PAINT A
DISTURBING PICTURE.
AT THE DISTURBING PICTURE OF
DR. FAUCI FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING WORRYING THAT HE HAD
BEEN FUNDING GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH.
AND HE KNOWS IT TO THIS DAY.
WE HAVE TO GET DEMOCRAT
COUNTERPARTS TO INVESTIGATE
THIS.
AND SO FAR IT'S BEEN SUCH A
PARTISAN SUPPORT FOR DR. FAUCI
THAT HE CAN DO NO WRONG.
BUT REALLY THERE'S A LOT OF...
SHE HAS A GREAT FEEL OF CONFLICT
OF INTEREST AND IF IT TURNS OUT
THIS VIRUS CAME FROM THE WUHAN
LAB, WHICH IT DOES SEEM LIKE A
DEAD, THERE'S CULPABILITY IN
THAT BIG SUPPORTER OF THE
FUNDING, BUT HE ALSO WAS A BIG
SUPPORTER TO THIS DAY OF SAYING
WE COULD TRUST THE CHINESE ON
THIS.
I THINK THAT'S QUITE NAIVE AND
TO REALLY SHOULD PRECLUDE HIM
FROM THE POSITION THAT HE IS IN.
>> Laura: REFERENCING THE
POINT YOU JUST MADE, SENATOR.
THE EMAILS -- THEY SHOW THAT
FAUCI WAS SCRAMBLING IN THOSE
EARLY DAYS OF THE PANDEMIC TO
FIND OUT THE LINKS BETWEEN THE
NIH FUNDED GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH AND COVID.
HERE IS HOW ONE OF HIS NIH
UNDERLINGS RESPONDED TO THIS
EMAIL ABOUT A 2015 GAIN OF
FUNCTION STUDY THAT WAS
COAUTHORED BY THE WUHAN
INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY.
HE SAID THE PAPER YOU SENT ME
SAYS THE EXPERIENCE WERE
PERFORMED BEFORE THE GAIN OF
FUNCTION PAUSE, BUT HAVE SINCE
BEEN REVIEWED.
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH THE P3
FRAMEWORK.
EXPLAIN THAT, SENATOR.
WHY IS THAT SO SIGNIFICANT?
>> HERE, LAURA, WHAT MAKES IT
WORSE.
TWO WEEKS AGO IN A COMMITTEE
HEARING HE SAID THEY DID NOT
FUND ANY GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH.
I QUOTED THAT SPECIFIC PAPER, SO
THE VERY PAPER HE PUTS IN THE
MEAL -- SHE SAYS OH, MY
GOODNESS, WE NEED TO READ THIS
PAPER BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE WE
ARE ACTUALLY FUNDING GAIN OF
FUNCTION RESEARCH, WHICH IS
WHERE WE JUICE UP THESE VIRUSES,
TAKE THEM FROM ANIMALS, AND
INFECT THEM IN HUMANS.
HE'S WORRIED ABOUT THIS IN
FEBRUARY OF LAST YEAR, BUT ONLY
TWO WEEKS AGO HE TELLS ME, OH,
IT WASN'T GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH.
BUT IN HIS EMAIL IN THE SUBJECT
LINE HE SAYS "GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH."
HE WAS ADMITTING THAT TO HIS
PRIVATE UNDERLINGS SEVEN, EIGHT,
NINE MONTHS AGO MONTHS AGO.
>> Laura: COULD THERE BE
CRIMINAL CULPABILITY HERE GIVEN
THE REPEATED FAILURES OF
DR. FAUCI, WHO WAS BASICALLY IN
CHARGE OF OUR MESSAGING ON THIS
AND ADVICE ON THIS.
COULD THERE BE CRIMINAL
CULPABILITY HERE OF FRAUD OR
ONGOING COLLABORATION WITH THE
CHINESE WHEN HE WAS MAKING
EXCUSES FOR THEM?
>> AT THE VERY LEAST, THERE IS
MORAL CULPABILITY.
IN THE RESEARCH DONE BY THE BAT
SCIENTIST IN WUHAN, SHE GIVES
HIM CREDIT.
SHE LISTS THE EXACT NIH GRANT
WITH THE I.D. NUMBER LISTING THE
MONEY AND THANKING THE NIH FOR
THE MONEY.
IT'S CLEARLY GAIN OF FUNCTION.
THERE ARE SEVERAL SCIENTISTS WHO
WERE IN THIS FIELD, CELLULAR
BIOLOGISTS, THEY ALL SAY THAT
TAKING A SARS VIRUS AND ADDING A
PROTEIN TO MAKE IT INFECT HUMAN
CELLS -- THAT IS THE VERY
DOMINATION OF GAIN OF FUNCTION.
IT'S VERY DANGEROUS.
WE SHOULDN'T BE DOING IT HERE OR
THERE, BUT DR. FAUCI HAS DENIED
IT TO THIS DAY.
BUT THE PRIVATE EMAILS SHOW HE
WAS ACKNOWLEDGING IT WAS GAIN OF
FUNCTION.
THE SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY NEEDS
TO LOOK AT THIS, BECAUSE HE
HIDES BEHIND THIS VEIL OF THE
LAB COAT THAT NOBODY CAN
QUESTION HIM.
>> Laura: YEAH WELL --
>> I BELIEVE THAT'S ABSOLUTELY
GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH.
AND TO THIS DAY HE STILL SAYING
IT DOWN LIKE HE WOULD DO IT
AGAIN.
>> Laura: ONE OF THOSE EMAILS
OBTAINED BY BUZZFEED, SENATOR,
WAS FROM PETER JOSH SCHELKE OF
THE ECO-HEALTH ALLIANCE.
HE WAS THE ONE PUSHING THIS AND
DOING THE RESEARCH THAT WAS
FUNDED BY NIH IN WUHAN.
SO HE WROTE TO FAUCI ON
APRIL 18TH 2020, I JUST WANT TO
SAY A PERSONAL THANK YOU FOR
PUBLICLY STANDING UP AND STATING
THAT THE SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
SUPPORTS A NATURAL ORIGIN FOR
COVID-19.
NOT A LAB RELEASE -- IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> HERE'S THE THING, LAURA.
PETER DOES THINK IS NOT A UNINTD
PARTY.
HE WAS THE FOUNDER OF THE
RESEARCH IN WUHAN, SO HE HAS A
SELF INTEREST AND NOT --
>> Laura: THAT'S MY POINT.
IT'S BECAUSE THAT'S MY POINT
TOO.
ANY INVESTIGATION GOING FORWARD,
IT CAN'T INCLUDE TONY FAUCI --
THEY WERE THE ONES WHO FUNDED
THE LAB.
THEY HAVE A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
COMING TO THE TRUTH.
>> Laura: WE WANT TO ASK ONE
MORE QUESTION WHICH IS ABOUT THE
TIMING OF THE LIFT OF THE
MORATORIUM ON THIS TYPE OF
RESEARCH, SENATOR.
IN JANUARY 9TH OF 2017, THE
NIAID RELEASED THIS STATEMENT
SAYING, WE'VE GONE THROUGH THE
REVIEWS AS TO WHY THIS TYPE OF
RESEARCH SHOULD BE PERMITTED.
IT WAS 11 DAYS BEFORE
DONALD TRUMP IS INAUGURATED.
AND IT'S LIKE A FOUR, FIVE PAGE
MEMORANDUM.
YOU CAN FIND THAT TIMING TO BE
INTERESTING?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THEY BAN IT FOR THREE YEARS AND
THEN RIGHT BEFORE DONALD TRUMP
BECOMES PRESIDENT, THEY ALLOW IT
AGAIN AND START GRANTING
EXEMPTIONS, ALL APPROVED BY
DR. FAUCI.
THE COMMITTEE'S SECRET -- THEY
WON'T LET YOU KNOW ON THE
COMMITTEE, BUT YOU KNOW
DR. FAUCI KNOWS WHO'S ON THE
COMMITTEE AND REVEALS THE STUFF.
BUT THEN THEY ALSO ALLOWED SOME
OF THE RESEARCH IN WUHAN NOT TO
GO BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
AND WHEN WOULD THEY WERE ASKED,
THEY SAID IT WASN'T GAIN OF
FUNCTION RESEARCH.
THEY BASICALLY DEFINED IT OUT OF
THE PURVIEW OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
ASSESSING SAFETY AND PREVENTING
DANGEROUS EXPERIMENTS FROM GOING
ON FOR THEIR SOMETHING ROTTEN IN
DENMARK AND SOMEBODY NEEDS TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS.
IT CAN'T INCLUDE TONY FAUCI
INVESTIGATING HIMSELF.
>> Laura: SENATOR, DO YOU HAVE
ANY FAITH THAT A BIPARTISAN
COMMISSION GIVEN THE LAWS THAT
HAVE BEEN PUT OUT THERE --
500,000 DEAD AND PEOPLE ARE JUST
LOOKING THE OTHER WAY?
>> WE CAN'T EVEN GET A HEARING,
BUT REALIZE WHAT THEY WERE
STUDYING IN THAT LAB THEY'VE
ADMITTED TO WAS 15 TIMES MORE
DEADLY THAN THE VIRUS WE ARE
DEALING WITH.
COVID-19 HAS ABOUT A 1%
MORTALITY, AND THAT'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE, BUT SARS, THE ONE FROM
2004, HAS A 50% MORTALITY.
AND THEY WERE TAKING SARS AND
JUICING DOPE AND MAKING IT MORE
INFECTIOUS TO HUMAN AIRWAY
CELLS.
THAT IS OVERLY SCARY THING TO
DO, PARTICULARLY FOR THE CHINESE
COMMUNISTS WHO I DON'T THINK ARE
THE MOST TRUSTWORTHY OF
PARTNERS.
>> Laura: AND AT LEAST PARTLY
FUNDED BY THE U.S. TAXPAYERS.
THAT IS A SCANDAL.
SENATOR, THANK YOU